Zootopia a roaring metropolis where  predator and prey lived peacefully going  about their daily business as they would  in any other urban jungle however every  city has its mysteries  let's open up the zpd Forensic Files and  investigate frozen from arendelle to  tundratown  this cold case has many clues throughout  the film let it go take down the  description of these two young gray and  wearing Anna and Elsa dresses adorable  for this guy duke weaselton who  suspiciously has a similar name to this  guy the duke of weaseltown sultan and he  even sounds familiar come on  why because both are voiced by alan  tudyk who made appearances in the last  four Walt Disney Animation Studios films  the second most obvious place for a  frozen reference after tundratown would  be Jumbo's cafe are you talking about  the frozen pattern on these plates are  all the rage of this elephant ice cream  parlor